[Musique]
Bonjour à tous j'en ai pas forcément
l'air mais je suis un révolutionnaire et
dans 10 minutes vous aurez tous en vie
dans les trains également je vous
présente et 3 destin qui devrait essayer
de vous convaincre on sera des
révolutionnaires Pacifique mais les
révolutionnaires quand même dans votre
vie vous avez des choix à faire vous
avez des ambitions et des projets à la
fin vous êtes une vous devrez vous avez
dû trouver un premier travail vous avez
envie de créer une famille la fonte des
de fonder une entreprise d'avoir une
start-up bref vous avez tous tes projets
ambitieux ou moins ça dépend le premier
le premier révolutionnaire je vous
présente ce soir c'est dur dur ça son
grand projet de vie c'était le créer son
propre pays donc une ambition plutôt
insolente il a voulu créer un pays de la
Liberté qui s'appelle l'île de la rose
c'est une île au milieu de la mer en
Italie proche de Rimini c'est idée il
est venu et c'était sa façon de dire
qu'il était pas d'accord avec les
institutions dans lesquelles il était né
après comme un frère un moment où il y a
du coup il y a voulu créer son
entreprise en Italie s'est rendu compte
que les procédures
pénible et illogique et n'était pas
forcément ce qu'ils voulaient avoir
comme institution durant toute sa vie au
lieu de les changer ou juste s'adapter
il y a décidé carrément de créer son
propre PC de la que tout est parti on
est donc en mai 1968 il faut mettre ça
dans son contexte on est dans une
période de libéralisation des mœurs et
dur dur ça avec sa bande d'amis il crée
une île artificielle l'île de la ronce
elle est fondée sur les pilotis au mieux
de la merde et puis le pied en métal et
cette aventure très rapidement elle
intéresse du tourisme de la région de
beaucoup de gens viennent faisait t-il
de la rose qui trouve très sympathique
et tout le monde veut faire la fête
passé un bon moment et ce succès il
énerve beaucoup les livres politiques
locales et les politiques en général en
Italie et encore plus puritaine et qui
s'énerve profondément de voir ce
troupeau de jeunes qui s'amusent jeunes
et moins jeunes qui s'amusent et qui en
plus d'être des rebelles qui ne
s'attaque pas les stars en fait ils
vivent complètement en dehors de l'État
il s'intéresse même pas ce que l'Italie
pense de tout simplement parce que ville
de la rose et la paix bâtiment dans le
territoire maritime de l'Italie mais
dans les eaux internationales pour
éviter avec l'Italie en théorie puisse
intervenir sur Lille et ça ça énerve
profondément l'Italie parce qu'en plus
d'avoir des gens qui ne correspondent
pas alors votre devis ils peuvent pas
intervenir
l'équipe de Giorgio ça ils sont partis
sur cette idée de créer leur propre pays
parce qu'ils ont une vision de la
liberté Kessel d'avoir le moins de
contraintes possible imposées par
d'autres ils souhaitent vivre sur leurs
propres mode de vie et avoir très peu de
personnes qui leur dise quoi faire c'est
que vous vous avez plus ou moins chacun
on a le droit de choisir son métier on
choisit sa compagne son compagnon mais
on choisit pas le pays dans lequel on
est né et on subit les institutions dans
lesquelles on est volume
si vous avez de la chance mais en Suisse
avec un quart de plus ou moins libre
mais ça peut arriver d'être né dans un
pays beaucoup plus liberticide pour
certains pays le slogan du pays indique
directement le programme prenant le
Mexique par exemple le slogan c'est la
Patrie d'abord votre la patrie passe
avant les individus on peut parfois
s'inquiéter entente avec du d'être
réellement respecté d'avoir ses libertés
qui sont assurés il y a d'autres pays
qui met l'individu au centre le
liberland par exemple Scénic relation
entre la Serbie et la Croatie Labalme le
slogan c'est vivre et laisser, on
comprend tout de suite que l'individu
est au centre et on le respecte on lui
fait confiance
toutes les idées existe car un cadre vie
il vous impose des choses et il vous
empêche d'en faire certaines autres il y
a pas tout le monde qui trouve ça
pertinent donc avant nous intéresser aux
deux prochains révolutionnaire on va
essayer de comprendre qu'est-ce qui les
amène à prendre des décisions et avoir
des projets autour du sucre et créer son
propre pays tu parts d'une révolution
interne d'une révolution interne ou une
question qui est posé par les
révolutionnaires c'est est-ce que je
suis en désaccord avec l'état dans
lequel j'habite parce que j'ai pas
encore le pouvoir et parce que
j'aimerais imposer la manière de boire
aux autres où est-ce que c'est le
pouvoir en son du tel qui me gêne et
l'idée qu'une majorité pour imposer sa
manière de voir à une minorité est
révolutionnaire se classe dans la
deuxième famille
c'est ce qui a motivé à notre deuxième
révolutionnaire aussi un Allemand si tu
es belle parce que ça le gênait que dans
sa vie il soit freiner par des décisions
prises par d'autres et qu'on lui imposer
alors que lui il n'y avait pas
acquiescer
ici aussi rendu compte que changer les
choses comme l'a fait dur dur ça a été
très compliqué et parfois chronophage il
voyait trois façons de changer les tu as
la première c'est prendre le pouvoir
parler du en deuxième se prend le
pouvoir par la rue en une révolution
violence et la troisième de faire
sécession dur dur ça et il trouve et ses
3 solutions chronophage et pas toujours
efficaces il y en a dans que développer
une 4e et la quatrième c'est de créer
des zones libres ou sans même des pays
sous forme de ville livre par exemple et
dans ces villes libre c'est plus les
tables partenaire mais c'est une
entreprise et cette entreprise en
contrepartie d'un montant vous payer
chaque année elle vous garantit votre
sécurité un cadre juridique stable et
également
une possibilité de gérer des éventuelles
différents devant un tribunal
indépendant la grande différence entre
ses livres saison de libre et les états
actuels avec le contrat vous avez signé
il évolue plus avec le temps et personne
peut le changer d'entreprise d'un tu as
le droit de le changer et si elle le
fait dois vous dès demain donc on change
complètement de logique ça devient des
endroits qui sont à politique qui a plus
des discussions une majorité peux
tyranniser les minorités comme
Tocqueville météorisé et c'est la grande
nouveauté c'est un livre se passerait
donc sur deux grands principes le
premier c'est que toute personne qui ne
dis pas aux autres as pas le droit
d'être embêter par le reste par la
majorité par le gouvernement et qu'elle
a droit de vivre comme elle le souhaite
la deuxième chose qui est importante
dans les livres c'est désormais toutes
les relations entre l'être humain elle
se base sur une base libre de
consentement et plus en partie sur la
conversation comme aujourd'hui parce que
dans les États moderne suite de choses
qui vous sera posé que vous devez faire
même si ça vous intéresse absolument pas
de résumé ça par le slogan de changer ce
qui vous dérange laisse sans déranger
les autres et finalement si c'est deux
solutions à vous paraissez trop pour
messieurs vous ne vous pressez pas il en
existe une troisième la troisième c'est
celle qui a choisi par Christophe fait
normal il se définit le même comme ça en
est à fixe parce qu'il voyage toute
l'année
c'est-à-dire 40 covit il prenait l'avion
et changer de pays régulièrement pour
éviter d'être sous le jour d'une les
expressions qui trouvait moralement pas
défendable qui voyageait de pays en pays
et puis il est lui-même conseiller
fiscal pour essayer de motiver d'autres
personnes à faire une chose que lui il
arrive à ville de ça et il donner des
conseils un peu partout autour de monde
évidemment avec le vide son modèle
d'affaires et c'est quelque peu remis en
question mais il a acheté un catamaran
il fait désormais le tour du monde sur
un bateau évidemment c'est pas une
solution qui est disponible pour tout le
monde déjà il faut éviter d'avoir le mal
de mer elle ne pas aimer l'avion et
surtout il faut être capable de
travailler de manière distante tout au
long de sa vie on a pu voir c'est 3
solutions avec trois façons d'être des
révolutionnaires s'il y a un État ne
nous correspond pas et maintenant à
titre individuel si vous souhaitez en
appliquer une il faut se poser la
question est-ce que l'État en place
permettre de faire ça est-ce que ce
désir de liberté sera permis
la question elle est limpide elle est
clair elle est rapide pas vraiment en
état dans un territoire donné il a un
monopole légal de la force ce qui fait
qu'il a des citoyens qui sont quasiment
des citoyens donc si il commence à
accepter des alternatives sur son propre
territoire ça va le forcer à être en
concurrence pas te forcer à se comparer
mais il se pourrait que la terre native
soit meilleur que son offre actuelle
donc il a pas d'un site actifed intérêt
personnel à autoriser c'est une
alternative
du coup on peut se poser la question
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'une institution
ne permet pas la concurrence et à mon
avis c'est très clair c'est qu'elle a
très peur de voir que son modèle et
finalement pas si efficace que ça et que
d'autres arrive avec moi de moyens avec
de nouvelles idées à faire mieux et du
coup être attirant pour des nouveaux
citoyens qui devrait nous questionner
pourquoi est-ce que les états comme ça
et pourquoi on se pose jamais cette
question du pouvoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on accepte une majorité a le droit
d'imposer c'est vision à une minorité de
manière très concrètes cette
non-disponibilité des étoiles pour les
alternatives te démontrer dans l'exemple
que j'ai pris au début de la rose elle a
existé quelques mois et ensuite l'État
italien fatiguée ma c'est de se faire de
se faire provoquer parce que c'est-il
qui était si moderne si dynamique et de
succès ils ont pris les moyens
militaires ils ont ils ont fait exploser
un coup de dynamique et c'est réaction
violente sont présentes partout dans le
monde des qu'un pop souhaite prendre son
indépendance
souhaite prendre son indépendance
je souhaite avoir une nouvelle aventure
qui sort du cadre légal et cette réponse
violence car sans doute la même absence
de confiance en son propre modèle et
tout ça devrait nous questionner
vous pouvez commencer cette révolution
intérieure j'ai évoqué avant que dur dur
ça et les autres ont traversé la
prochaine fois quand vous recevrez un
bulletin de vote lisez les objets de
rotation et demander vous si vous êtes
dans la position est-ce que c'est juste
un peu aux autres ce que vous pensez
est-ce que c'est juste une majorité sur
ce thème peut imposer sa position et
minorité est-ce qu'une façon juste de
faire avec sa moto révolution intérieure
commencera et avec la présentation de ce
soir vous avez maintenant un petit guide
du révolutionnaire Pacifique pour faire
ce chemin intérieur j'espère que le
prochain dur dur ça a été dans cette
salle ce soir et si c'est le cas
peut-être l'année prochaine on pourra
suivre les ai dit tu es à Martigny mets
sur une île artificielle sur le lac
Léman
[Applaudissements]